despite the horrifying coronavirus
numbers i uh told you about earlier in
the show donald trump is now holding
daily rallies or even multiple rallies
each day
at least one of these rallies has now
been specifically tied to more than 20
cases of coronavirus
but that's a different story the real
story here for us today
is that at his latest rallies donald
trump has become
even more authoritarian than we've seen
him be uh be before
including vowing to lock up the bidens
which we will also discuss
in a moment but these rallies are a true
dystopian nightmare
including trump having the entire crowd
boo and jeer at the media the exact
opposite of a president who respects a
free press
but there's also a desperate and almost
practical
realistic element of trump at these
rallies trump
seems to be recognizing that he indeed
might lose to joe biden in just a little
over two weeks
and trump also seems to recognize or or
at least admit
that it would be very embarrassing for
him to lose because as he says
biden is the worst candidate in history
that that's not
true but the real reason it would be
embarrassing for trump to lose is with
all the bluster with all the the
narcissism and and the
attacks on the left and on joe biden
there would be an
irony in trump losing to a guy he claims
is a terrible opponent but there's one
thing that donald trump has now said
in some form um in terms of
one state like for example trump has
previously said in the last couple of
weeks
he goes to north carolina and says north
carolina if you don't vote for me i'm
never coming back to north carolina iowa
if you don't vote for me i'm never
coming back to iowa
but now trump has taken it up a notch
which is actually quite interesting
trump says if he loses to joe biden
he might leave the country check out
this clip from his make and georgia
rally a few days ago
i shouldn't drop because you know what
running against
the worst candidate in the history of
presidential politics puts pressure on
me
could you imagine if i lose my whole
life what am i going to do
i'm going to say i lost to the worst
candidate in the history of politics
i'm not going to feel so good maybe i'll
have to leave the country i don't know
[Applause]
so this is fascinating for a few reasons
first it's clear trump's primary
feeling will be embarrassment if he
loses that's predictable thanks to
trump's ego
and his narcissism now there are some of
you who will say
narcissists like trump can't feel shame
he will just say that it was rigged yes
of course he will say it
but there is no doubt that privately at
least it will be hugely embarrassing to
trump if he loses to joe biden
which i would love to see second there's
the idea of
hiding if he loses and this is becoming
more and more commonly mentioned
indirectly i've said before
in the immediate aftermath if donald
trump does lose
he may well deny he lost claim it was
rigged be on twitter
24 7 be doing you know press briefings
all the time
accusing this that and the other person
of cheating him out of whatever
but if it is eventually undeniable
that trump lost if joe biden is going to
be the next president of the united
states i wouldn't be shocked to see
trump all but disappear just sort of
evaporate into the ether
and the idea of never going to states he
loses again and now of leaving the
country
is another indicator not literally i
don't believe trump will literally leave
the country
but the underlying emotion of the idea
is there that trump will just kind of
disappear and you won't hear from him
again
the reality is i think the idea
of a trump-free united states would be
so
welcomed by tens of millions at minimum
that the only way
trump would really consider leaving the
united states leads us directly into
layer three of this conversation which
is the idea of donald trump
evading prosecution after being
president now by the way
is trump says he's patriotic and his
party is patriotic
is there anything patriotic about saying
you will abandon your country if you're
democratically removed
but again i don't think it is literal
but think about what leaders leave their
countries
after their reigns of terror are over
it's authoritarian dictators
fleeing arrest fleeing consequences this
is something we've come to see
many times globally when authoritarians
lose their grip on power
they go to a country without extradition
to live out
the rest of their lives and if i must
tell you
there are plenty of countries that would
no doubt love
to make use of a former american
president who will just
trash talk the united states and trump
would easily find safe haven if in
plenty of places if that's what he
wanted to do
he would become he would be welcomed
to become a sort of uh weaponized
agent of social discord much like his
presidency has been
i know many of you are obviously
thinking about russia this is bigger
than russia okay now the realization
that i came to as i was watching this
farce take place in macon georgia was
if we don't want all of this exact same
stuff to happen again in four years
we have to make sure that this guy is
removed now all of these questions about
trump leaving coming
all this different stuff we've got to
remove him now
talk about making america great again by
the way trump leaving and ideally taking
those kids of his with him
that would be one of the most powerful
steps donald trump could take
to improve this country and if you're
not yet convinced of that
let's look at some more clips from a
recent rally that donald trump did
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video